[Music]
welcome to ear biscuits the podcast
where two lifelong friends talk about
life for a long time
i'm link and i'm rhett this week at the
round table of dim lighting we are
listening to your voicemails that you
left at one eight eight eight earpod one
answering the question or completing the
sentence i said one three times which i
guess was confusing but if you dial
extra numbers yeah you just get the
extension 11 which is us
um i could not have survived my teenage
years without
fill in the blank
boy
is that all you got to say
you thought i was going to start talking
boy
but well i know i was just thinking
about what i couldn't have survived my
and actually you know what we got a lot
of answers that were in the when i think
about my teenage years and what i
couldn't have survived without i think
about uh
whacking off
okay right and i'm just saying that
apparently many of you also agree with
that because i would say that
uh more than 50 of the answers were uh
people talking about masturbation no
there no there weren't yeah they were
oh really yeah no they weren't
am i right
yes oh they were yeah i'm not this is
not a joke this is based on knowledge
that i have about all the calls that
were made over half
it's just a good amount i mean
i'm saying over 50 of you well you know
what know thyself said that you could
not have gotten through your teenage
years without masturbating do you okay
and you know what
i'm right there with you
[Laughter]
so we're not going to talk about that
other than right now we're getting it
out of our system
that's it that's all the masturbation
talk that's kind of what it is isn't it
getting it out of your system
it doesn't really work at all it seems
to always be ready to go again
i mean there is a reset period but it
depends on how old you are
oh really the older you get the longer
the reset period gets i mean
i i do recall
when i was when i was really
making it into an art form
testing the limits i would chat i
challenged myself
mm-hmm
just to see what would happen we didn't
we don't have to talk about this now oh
okay we don't have to you're the one who
brought it up no they brought it up and
we didn't select any of those no we're
not yeah we talk about it now we decided
not to talk about it except now i didn't
even know we didn't even select those
yeah i know i was trying to keep it from
you you called them i didn't think your
ears were ready for it
i know it makes you uncomfortable i mean
i think i could have survived without it
but uh i mean the thing that i
if i if i had to do it multiple times
just string them together that's what i
couldn't have survived because that's
that's a lot of work
that takes a lot
i don't understand i lost i lost the
plot
don't make me say it
if you if you want to string them
together
like rapid succession when i was testing
the limits of
it's just that's a lot of work yeah yeah
yeah
you're still lost uh it gets where it's
almost not enjoyable oh it's almost like
a duty
right
it's like you're just a donor
right
yeah i gotta get paid
oh man if we keep this up this would be
like me my dad's podcast yeah i heard
it's really dirty
he's a dirty boy
i i egg him on you know it's fun we're
having a good time over there um
speaking of having a good time i am
excited about listening to these
voicemails
and
i i just like it i'm also i i like have
a good time
i like have a good time is that what i
said i like have a good time and the
best time that i've ever had on the
internet was um good mythical eating
well that was really that was why i was
talking about uh i went ahead and just
broke the seal and started talking about
masturbation it has nothing to do with
good mythical evening well but it's the
kind of thing we would just talk about
we'd talk about it and we would probably
we would we would use no more explicit
language okay sure yeah we would because
it's an r rated version of good mythical
morning i gotta say if you were there
for made waves last year then you know
you want to be there for it again
because we're doing it thursday
september 1st
all right we're doing it that evening
it's one night only ticketed event
exclusively on moment house
um that's that's the provider don't get
too worked up yeah grab your tickets at
goodmythicalevening.com
friday or if you're a mythical society
member you can get it uh wednesday yeah
those society members are there getting
things early but yeah good mythical
evening i'm
it's september 1st like i said so i'm
already gearing up for it yeah you got
to make plans for it yeah you got to
save up i'm going to challenge myself
this year um
in what way
see how many i can string together how
many good mythical evenings oh okay okay
i only did one evening last time i'm
gonna cram two evenings into one this
year yeah yeah i don't know if i'm
prepared for that
uh yeah if you don't know uh last year
link
uh had fun he got a little uh carried
away um
we knew that we were going to be
taking some shots to get ready
but
we underestimated
um
how much of a lightweight
he yes and as soon as he started talking
i was like whoa okay i thought this was
going to be like a progressive evolution
over the course of the night but it was
just like no no bam out of the canyon
yeah yeah we are starting
on
so i just basically have made a
commitment that i'm that i'm going to be
right there with you this this this uh
this this time
boom so now that i know what to expect
stevie's not reporting to this poor
stevie of course
she's going she's gonna be the one that
had to keep us on track petrified
she was petrified last year a lot a lot
of people watching were petrified
yeah it was fun
it was fun
and uh it's more fun if you're there
good
um
let's listen to uh response
am i playing these
well you've got the computer okay
hi rhett and link my name is kat um i
could not have survived my teenage years
without
the lunches that my mom packed for me
specifically
i had braces for a very long time so my
teeth were always sore and she would
always make me ramen in a thermos and
the noodles would soak up all the liquid
and every time i opened the theramis it
looked like a brain so i guess i
couldn't have survived my teenage years
without um
ramen that looked like a brain thank you
you're welcome cat
what a pleasant voice that cat's got
should be on radio
being radio being podcasting right
welcome to the future no no no the the
radio standard is a little bit above
podcasting
did your mom ever pack you ramen in a
third i like to go into a bit of a radio
voice from time to time
um but uh i got to tell you that i do
think that a podcast voice is a little
bit more suited to what we're doing
right now but i am full-on ready
to go radio to go radio if i have to
don't do it i'll do it in a heartbeat i
would love to have a late night show
where i was talking to people about
aliens and weird and stuff like that uh
like coast to coast coast to coast i
might do that in my old in my old days
in my elder times
uh where you just sit there and you
listen to people and you give them the
benefit of the doubt you don't question
them you never question where they're
talking about you just egg them on right
and you just have a crazy old
conversation
i love that idea
i love it too
you're invited oh okay i'm working on it
you're working on it i'll work on it
who's doing coast to coast now uh it's
still happening and in fact i was
listening
first of all
just so you know
we're gonna have to do a podcast about
aliens before long because well they're
gonna arrive we just keep talking about
it so much and we haven't even let the
mythical beasts in on the fact that
there's lots of alien talk that's been
happening around here and between us and
amongst friends and
you know my days of extreme skepticism
about that well i'm still a skeptic but
you know i don't know maybe la's finally
getting to me
but we got to talk about it before long
man
and anyway i was listening to a podcast
where they were talking about aliens
which there's a lot there's a few of
them we won't be breaking any new ground
nope
and the guy was talking about coast to
coast and he was talking and he was
saying that like yeah you were on coast
to coast and he was like yeah with
with the with the with the with the
you know the old boy whatever his name
is
um coast to coast
he's still doing you said hosta
hosta
uh jim
george nori yeah george nori yeah he's
still doing it from 1988 until now
he's still doing it george nori
george nori i can't i don't i can't do
an impersonation but he does take
everyone very seriously
that's his stick i love it look at what
cat got you on she got you on alien she
used to talk about her mom made a ramen
in a thermos dude
my mom would make me a thermos full of
stuff and i would love it she didn't
make you a thermos she took out some
soup
warmed it up and put it have you ever
heard about make a pot of soup yeah
you're not making the pot make a thermos
of soup she didn't make she got he was
canned man stay out of this your mom was
between me and your mom was putting
canned soup into your thermos you know
what else she was putting more than you
were doing
she was also putting hamburger helper in
there that was my jam cheeseburger
hamburger helper in a thermos
that was my favorite it was better
as a leftover
how did you eat it out of there did you
pour it out and eat it with a spoon i
just dipped it out with a spoon you were
there
i don't watch that kind of thing when
it's happening some uh somebody eating
hamburger helper out of a thermos i
blocked it out because it kept it hot
well i understand that but then when
eating it you're sticking a spoon all
the way down in the bottom of a thermos
what kind of spoon did you have how
about your thermos is that big
you got an extra long spoon
i don't remember that part
gee maybe it's all a lie
i'm disturbed thinking about it so i
really relate to this ramen i never had
braces
i wish i did
but that ship has sailed well here's the
thing
i had them
and then i uh
was given that
you know i was given that permanent
bottom retainer because something about
the human mouth the bottom teeth are the
ones that like to venture back keep
moving
and uh and then you know just
not too long ago 10 years ago the
dentist is like
if that thing's bothering you we can
take it off he took it off and gave me a
retainer that i had to put in at which
point
uh reality
intersected with me which means i don't
do things like continue to wear
retainers because that requires a
certain level of focus and discipline
that i don't have
so well why did you say oh you didn't
show my bottom teeth got crooked
actually i can't lift your chin up dude
or where your chin would be tilt your
head up
i'm showing you the outline right there
oh my god it's very clear doing that
it's not going to show you anything oh
yeah yeah i got you it's not as bad as
mine though
uh mine definitely not as bad as yours
but jank but uh i will say that most
why did you tell him to remove the
retainer it's not it wasn't bothering
you it had been in there for 30 years no
every single time i went to the dentist
they would be like oh you got a lot of
build up on this retainer oh
okay whatever
so i mean well hold on but i'm saying
you shouldn't feel bad about your bottom
teeth i don't know what it is but bottom
teeth being crooked
not really seen as a problem just watch
start looking at the bottom teeth of
actors on television
american actors i mean i'm not talking
brits they got their teeth are all over
the place i'm talking
oh yeah okay uh i love you i love you i
love you england i'm just you know it's
a stereotype anyone can take a joke yeah
you guys have taken over the world uh
imperialism all that we can make some
jokes about you um
the uh the bottom teeth of american
actors are regularly uh janked it
doesn't matter and uh look i mean look
at me i'm successful right but if the
top teeth start getting out of whack a
lot of that success is from emanates
from my face if the the top teeth start
getting out of whack we have to start
thinking about casting decisions
okay does this does this cop seem like
they would have crooked top teeth
because it's a different thing it's just
a different thing yeah nothing against
people would crooked top teeth it's just
a different thing it's a different
casting you don't have anything to say
about school lunch uh my mom stopped
packing lunch for me uh before high
school so i didn't take lunch during
high school uh
oh yeah that's that's true i didn't i
took my i actually did a bunch a whole
episode of this uh talking about school
lunch on uh stevie's podcast best
friend's back all right check that out
all right let's play another one then
hey rhett and link yo uh my name is
keoni and i could not have survived my
teenage years without video games let me
tell you
that stuff
stress reliever okay
y'all are kind of old so like you might
not get it but that's all right
okay love you bye
you love us because
we love us old guys
they had video games when we were coming
up man yeah they just weren't good they
weren't good they weren't as addictive
they were not as immersive i mean you
can only
then definitely not as connecting well
think about it you're watching mario
run sideways
you feel you feel like you are not mario
you know what i'm saying like it's not
immersive i never once thought i was
mario you're not seeing mario you're wha
you're controlling someone else that
you're watching never once thought i was
looking but once you move into this
first person perspective do you think
that's it
now you got something that's addictive
in a different way i'm just kind of
making this up as i go which is most of
the time what i'm doing but i'm just
saying pov pov
you know the amount of first person
perspective
in your gaming experience that's how you
relate the level of addiction it's such
a huge part of um
i mean lincoln 17 now for the past you
know four years five years
it's it's a huge part of his social life
you know he connects with his friends
playing video games i you know i
understand and respect that but at a
certain point we're like let's let's do
the real world thing especially post
pandemic we had to like shake him out of
those habits
connecting with any npcs
because that's what you've got to really
work watch out for what is that
oh you haven't been paying attention um
is that that's dad get with the program
what is that a um non-player character
it's just you know an ai generated
character in a game that isn't
it's just a you know it's an impeachment
pertinent to the story yeah it might be
pertinent to the story but it's not
controlled by a person oh yeah it's not
an avatar okay yeah no he's not you
don't want to make too big of a
connection with an npc because then
you're supposed to all right
i don't know because a lot of people
have a lot of connections to npcs and
that can again that can lead to if you
are i'll have to ask if you if your pov
is connecting with npcs then you're
asking your sol exactly
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah but lily
was never
lilly
she never connected with friends playing
video games with him even though she
would play
she played overwatch a little bit back
when that was the thing yeah shepard
shepherds aren't going to fortnite
shepard's our gamer in the family he's
the one that has his like buddies that
they regularly get on there and play
together locke played
um like
nba 2k
for a while and then high school rolled
around he completely stopped playing
video games just didn't i just made the
decision not to and did other things
yeah he was just he's just into
different things yeah i mean
yeah for us it was never
you know i i got nintendo power just so
i could uh i got the subscription just
so i could talk talk the lingo but i
just did not
i just did not have the commitment to
beat any game ever like it just did not
interest me that much
and it never has since then
like i'm not i
i know there are certain points when
you're currently tempted you told me two
days ago i'm thinking that you wanted to
go away for a week
and do nothing but
play a video game
like 24 hours a day you wouldn't say 24.
when you weren't sleeping 12 to 16. you
wanted to like literally like become a
gamer well okay i'm glad you brought
this up because i have been thinking
about it and i just mentioned it to you
two days ago but
i said that um yeah i'm just saying it
was it was it was that i've been
thinking about it for a while it's only
that you know about it since then
so
yes i do have a personality that if you
put me in like a challenging environment
which is a video game in a lot of ways
and there's a gold and so i can get
fixated on that
and i actually don't let myself play
video games or even games on my phone
really because
uh
i just don't i don't have time right now
are you done with wordle
uh
wordle is not every single day anymore
wordle is like
a few times a week it's not the first
thing in the morning
so but wordle's not a game it is it's a
game but yeah so
but what i have i've had this idea that
maybe in my older age
when i don't have as many
responsibilities
that i'll be like
it would be cool to just
say like i'm setting aside a certain
amount of time and i'm going to
completely immerse myself in one of
these incredible games having gone away
from games
after the first nintendo pretty much
you had a genesis yeah at the same time
same same era he didn't care i didn't
even have a super nintendo i didn't even
get on that train so
to come back to the system now that is
just so advanced
and then be like i'm going to get lost
in this immersive world and i'm just
going to see what it's like to just like
eat cheetos drink mountain dew
have a sleeping bag
next to okay a gaming chair i have a
gaming chair with like a sleeping bag
next to it
in like a cabin
with a good wi-fi
and i'm gonna why does it have to be a
cabin that has nothing to do i don't
want anyone to see this it could be a
closet
yeah but i don't want anyone to be close
to me
well i mean smelling like cheetos and
mountain dew yeah you'll be in a closet
um but i have to come out at some point
and you want to do this for a week i but
i think but so then i started thinking
why wait until i get old and do it and
why not make it into content while i'm
still young and people care about the
content foray into the gaming it's like
rhett takes a week
goes deep into a game like
what's the l what's the one that
everybody elder elder ring elder elden
ring the other ring
what's about what are the scrolls that's
the elders
god we don't know man
hold on there's those old scrolls and
then there's old rings and which one's
better
i believe that the elden rings ring is a
video game is it is it one ring or is it
mini rings
anyway the thing i'm worried about is
that i'll suck so bad at the mechanics
of it because of all the buttons
that's why vr is gonna leapfrog bring me
back into this
uh man i gotta i have i've got a vr
headset so do you
yeah yeah here's my face you know just
just wait for it just wait for it it's
gonna stop hurting my face man
i wanted to be like ready player one
but you know what i get it caller
i couldn't quite understand your name
uh it was quiet
well
yeah
sort of dropped out at that point i get
it
i get it though hey guys i could not
have survived my teenage years without
my crocs
now i know what you're thinking
shoes
not only are they simulating what i
imagine walking on clouds is like they
are also reliable and sturdy being a
free sport athlete the croc is the most
practical shoe after your sport is over
and you want to take off your sweaty
footwear
i actually survived a hairy moment in my
crocs too
my mother wasn't paying attention one
day when she picked me up from school
and thought i was already in the car
i wasn't
she started driving off with my foot
underneath the tire my foot the croc
unbroken that clock shaved my foot and
let's not forget to mention that a croc
can go from cruise control to sport mode
real quick with a simple strap maneuver
anyways thanks for listening have a
splendid week thanks guys
wow elise myers thanks for calling us
you sound like elise yeah a little bit
well also i really appreciate that you
scripted that before you called in
don't don't expose no i'm just saying
that i know i'm not making fun i'm
saying that i mean you don't don't crawl
attention to it i liked it too but i
know i'm saying i like i don't want
people you're the one making you seem
like it's a problem no i'm not if you
don't know what you're going to say you
can script it out and call in just like
this person don't acknowledge it make it
seem like you know what that was a well
put together call
can i just say it was a well-written
call
no that's one
because i have to believe that people
are you're making people not want to do
that because they're going to i'm never
going to say it again i'm never going to
point it out this is the first caller
who read who read their response we
think you read it
i will never acknowledge it i will never
acknowledge it again
okay now let's talk about the content
all right we don't have to have a meta
conversation about every call
i mean um i i i was hating on crocs from
a distance i gotta say i mean we're well
into summer i haven't seen you i haven't
seen you in a public place with those
crocs yet you wore them one time to my
house and i was wearing socks yeah i put
them on this morning because i couldn't
find my flip-flops but without socks
to take the dogs out oh well that
doesn't come out and my feet immediately
feel sweaty even even before they are
and then they get sweaty in the crocs
like i can't
i have to wear flip-flops and i'm not
even a particularly sweaty foot person i
bought some foot sweat deterrent why
don't
i
i like the crocs with the socks i get it
i understand it's like they're in and
out and then i like the sport mode yeah
if you need it if you're gonna
i didn't know that if your foot got run
over while wearing them i thought that
was just luck i think that was luck i
don't think croc croc did anything
but i did get some some you know i when
coming up i had uh my because i had very
sweaty hands and very sweaty feet
as i've gotten older the problem has got
much less pronounced oh but you couldn't
have survived your teenage years without
drysol
how do you remember the name of that
because
uh
i don't know man i you know i care about
you i got a i got to be a repository for
the stuff that matters well there's a
new product that is better
uh didn't it work though it was like you
put a little a little drop on your hand
it's the same thing you drop on your
other hand and you rub them together and
then they wouldn't sweat well
that was wooden sweat is debatable it
wasn't like a miracle cure you know you
can get botox in your palms if you've
got really like some kid some teens will
get botox in the
did your glasses have a camera in them
because you just like i eat sure i just
i just the way you grabbed you yeah you
grabbed your glasses in a way with two
hands that you never have and it was
like does he have those facebook ray
bands
uh first of all have you seen ads for
those
the facebook ray bans
no what do you mean facebook ray bans
what you don't know about this
this is months old but i saw an ad
recently and i was like oh that's that
they're still trying to do that ray
about facebook
you don't have to give a [ __ ] about
facebook do you care about ray-bans
yeah
what are you talking about dude
ray-ban and facebook or meta have are
collaborating on a product that is a
stylish pair of classic ray-bans that
have a camera in them to capture all and
share all the moments in your life
you don't know about this man you need
to look at billboards more
because there's one on the billboard
that's what i was reminded of you know
what that's good advice but it was but
it started looking up billboard but it
was but it was like in the news in a
pretty big way like last year i promise
you right from now on i'm gonna be
looking at billboards more um so
i thought that maybe you had those i
don't we don't have to get into a
conversation about that but i think
you're really tangent prone today
yeah stay on target man talking about
crocs no we're talking about hand sweat
so i had dry saw there's a new product
called carp
put in um
google
hand sweat
hand sweat stopper carp
because they got a this is i think it
was a kickstarter they have all kinds of
stuff
carp
like the fish yeah there it is
carpe no
carpe max like carpe diem so they have
them for your feet your hands it's
probably all the same stuff maybe in
different concentrations palmar
hyperhidrosis that's what you had
uh-huh and it runs in the family because
my kids have it too so i so i basically
handle lotion so i'm not a sponsor of
course so i started you you've seen the
little uh
speaking of like crocs you've seen those
little leather slipper things that i've
been wearing which are like kind of like
leather crocs yeah
and
a couple of weeks ago when the weather
hadn't quite heated up yet i could wear
those and be like right this is okay
i tried wearing them yesterday oh boy
and uh or was it today did i come in
here with them on who cares yeah it's
today we do too much in one day it
becomes two days in my mind wow this
morning i came in here with those things
on what did you do with that i took them
off and put on so i have other shoes
here and i put on other shoes because i
was like my feet are sweating too much
and i was like i gotta get this stuff i
have it i ordered it i just haven't put
it on my feet yet you have to put on
your feet every night though
it's not sexy i i think
i don't know i'm not gonna i'm not it
may become a sponsor so i'm gonna look
into it more before i start getting
concerned about if it's gonna stop up
your feet feet pores well it literally
call us it literally physically i don't
want to do that clogs i'm just going to
say it literally clogs your pores with
i think some sort of compound maybe
aluminum don't quote me on that
then your sweat just finds another way
out do you
like crocs
not with socks
so your feet don't sweat in crocs
i don't have any
well yeah you do you were given the red
crocs the same time i was and then i uh
i gave them to uh yeah i donated them to
the company somebody here at mythical
has them yeah size 12. we're great
bosses
i see people wearing my clothes
if we have clothes that we don't like
and we don't want anymore we give it to
our employees
i see
we don't dock their pay it's an honor
system they dock their own yeah right
right right you decide what it's worth
all right let's take
another oh hey written link this is nico
calling from pittsburgh pa and i
definitely could not have survived my
teenage years without mountain dew um
easy way of summing it up as someone who
now graduated high school eight years
ago now i'm feeling all just saying that
uh when you're a drummer in a band
growing up uh you learn that if you want
to melt faces
gotta do the do you gotta have that
energy coming from somewhere especially
when energy drinks are not only
dangerous but a little on the pricey
side at least
how it was back then and i know it's
pretty much how it is now but uh
definitely could not have survived it
without good old mountain dew okay any
variety too all right nico
last year thanks guys
i think nico might be a toll booth
worker
yeah well it's based on the sounds i'm
just trying to piece together the
setting if you're going to talk about
mountain dew you might as well figure it
out there's like engines
people are doing the do
behind him or all around him yeah he
could be at one of those sometimes
people will gather in parking lots and
uh
play around with uh remote control have
you seen how crazy the remote control
stuff can get these days
have you have you been
we're talking about the do man i'm just
following i'm just following my
instincts today it's like here
man you're
speaking of mountain dew i'm just saying
no have you just been out and about in
this town and then all of a sudden it's
just like out of nowhere control planes
no no i'm talking like drones i'm
talking to like a real badass car car
just comes out of nowhere and then
you're like where's the dad in the sun
where are they right and then you see
them whoa you're walking where in like a
i'm this i've been i have a parking lot
to a gal i've been cornered by remote
control vehicles seven times in my time
in la sometimes i've been on a trail
sometimes i've been in a parking lot
sometimes i've been on the sidewalk
sometimes i've been walking down the
street my neighborhood bam there it is
i prefer to be in the thing that's
moving you know what i'm saying yeah i'm
not saying i'm an advocate i'm just
saying i'm just you sound like an
advocate i'm just i'm just saying i'm
just this is an awareness play
uh
ar we can relate to this nico though
because we couldn't have gotten through
without mellie yellow oh god i mean how
much mellie yellow did we drink i mean
we just we couldn't drink enough of it
like i we felt like it was it was like
it's like we had an exclusive deal i
guarantee you you didn't drink as many
as me of course not because i would get
home i know i would get home and we did
not keep them in the fridge because they
moved too fast my mom kept her diet coke
and caffeine-free diet coke depending on
the time of day in the refrigerator the
mellow yellow was kept you know where it
was on the floor next to the onion and
potatoes box everybody had that yeah and
then i would get home from a hot hot day
i would reach down i'd pop that thing
open i'd grab a mellow yellow i'd
i'd say i'd pound the first one then i
get a second one and go sit down with it
both hot
both hot and both full
carbonated sugary caffeinated drinks
the first i didn't understand what was
happening we didn't we didn't have the
education no one told us about caffeine
like i would go home and pound five
cigarettes
okay
this is not the 50s
this is the 80s i mean but it kind of
feels like cigarettes you know well we
didn't know we didn't know about it
like we weren't educated on you just
can't pound a bunch of mellow yellows
like that it didn't have an impact but
do you ever remember making the
connection between caffeine and being
wired and like being i can't sleep
tonight must have been those seven
mellow yellows i had at dinner never
how come
the internet
makes people so much smarter you know it
makes them dumber too but just think
about how dumb we were man we didn't
know anything were there kids in the 80s
who knew about this stuff i had when's
the last time you had a melee
i wanna yellow get one right now
every time we talk about this this is
how this part of the conversation is do
you think we can find one right now they
haven't been a gas station uh if you go
to one of those um like 100
soft drink fountain drink machines the
coke coke machine like what guys have
the coke remix what is it called coke
yeah oh man they got them in the
theaters at amc theaters yeah
five guys has one and you can get a
mellow yellow zero yeah i've had it and
you know what i'm tempted to just start
ordering those off the internet but i
don't want to no no i don't want to be
drinking
a bunch of those
i'm not a doctor i like it being
a treat i don't think you should make
diet soda
or definitely not soda but i don't think
you should make diet soda a part of your
daily routine because
that uh diet soda does some stuff to
your to your body your biome like your
gut biome
and i just don't think you need it in
there there's artificial sweeteners man
we don't know what they're doing it
might be worse than sugar probably not
but like
i just have it as an occasional treat
while i'm here in the office
don't don't don't get started that's
what i think too but i i happen to be
looking at a reddit thread
this guy he might have been on twitter
he wasn't a billboard he quit won a
billboard
he said i quit diet coke i've been
drinking him my whole life
i quit for a whole month
i'm here to report i'm here to report
my life has not changed for the better
i i haven't i haven't
gotten in better shape i haven't lost
weight well he went on to say that i'm
not feeling it i'm not happy anymore i'm
not happy
all these people were talking about hey
man people were like
coming into the thread and saying
well you know i tried all these things
to make my body better and then i got
cancer so drink your drink your diet
coke and i was like gosh this is this is
like a what's the word uh like a jaded
group of
society where they're like kind of
snarky and jaded can't think of the word
snarky and jaded people you're thinking
about nihilists
notice a little better is it the
nihilist a little bitter um
you know i it does suck this like if you
try to do everything right and you try
to be healthy you got to choose you you
got to choose your moments at least
you're like
you're you're you're happy little
indulgences i'm not going to judge
anyone for for doing it i'm drinking but
people were like coming out of the
woodwork to tell this this guy keep go
back to drinking your diet coke yeah but
here's the thing
you're not happy the thing you were
probably
uh really
enjoying in the diet coke is the
caffeine there are other vehicles for
caffeine here's one of them right here
not a sponsor but we drink the hell out
of this stuff
this yerba mate that's better for you
than uh
than diet coke and coffee
they're fine here it is right here you
know coffee they're finding now that
people who drink coffee specifically
there was a study that said that people
who drink
coffee sweetened so people who drink
coffee are less likely to get
i think it was cancer
uh but people who drink sweetened coffee
for some reason are more unlikely to
like 30 less likely not just one study
but there's other sources of caffeine
but while we're talking about that and i
said the thing about gut biome i have to
also talk about
i've told you about the kefir kick i'm
on right now and i have to and i have to
tell you i love kefir but i can't get it
in a big enough container
well you get multiple of small ones i
don't like that but let me tell you
there's only like two and a half
servings in the thing
listen i know you think you might just
think we just went all like we did we
did i love kefir it's tangy i love
yogurt
but
the and i'm not one of these people that
my mouth is watering right now like
talking about like probiotics and like i
you know a lot of probiotics just like
it's kind of bs and doesn't really get
through your system whatever but let me
tell you right now
so i just had this idea that i was gonna
get back into kiefer because i liked it
but i was like what i usually do is i
get one and i go through it and then it
takes weeks to get the second one it
doesn't become a part of my routine yeah
and you go through it quick right and so
i just told jesse i was like i would
like you to have
uh three things
kefir
kimchi
okay in kombucha oh
and it's unfortunate those those are
three cases there's got to be a better
way to refer to them so i'm working on
that i'm work i'm workshopping the way i
refer to this because it cannot be the
kkk diet
because that's not it's not it's not
going to be that okay
but it you know what already exists
this is that reality so those three k's
obviously are all very probiotic lots of
people just consider these things to be
like
lifetonics right and so i was like i
like all three of these things i l i i
feel good
but the one that i have not
wavered from at all for about three
months is kefir
either if i don't have it in the morning
i have it at night and i get at least a
cup
throw some granola in there throw some
berries in oh you
you eat it as a meal you eat it as a
snack
this drink this is the ticket
for breakfast lately i've been doing
cereal but instead of milk is kefir
listen don't write that down because i'm
gonna put it in my recipe book
but uh
i i don't like this idea but okay but
the really the thing i'm trying to
communicate here is that give key for a
chance this is what happened what
happened i started
i was gonna say i started taking it i
started eating it
and i i didn't have anything in mind
other than like mountain dew you started
doing it i started doing keyframes doing
the keys and
and i was and i and i forgot marketing
by the way mountain dew has like it's
subconsciously said they're a drug okay
look let me i gotta get this out get it
out you keep interrupting me okay so i'm
i start drinking kefir
and then i
just kind of forgot that i was doing it
but it had become a daily thing
i'm having a conversation with my
therapist and i told him i'm like
you know i'm a generally happy person
right i am i'm a pretty happy person you
know i haven't i have never been like
diagnosed with a depression or anything
like that i go through like anybody i go
through like depressive states or sad
states or whatever
but i'm pretty happy
but i kept finding myself over the
course of a couple of weeks with no
external thing to explain it
being like i keep realizing that i'm
happy okay it was just weird because it
hadn't happened before
i said i'm not the kind of person who
realizes that they're happy and like
stops and thinks
how happy
that's
that's strange noted
started talking to my therapist about it
and then i was like
didn't pick up on it in the first
session but then like a couple of
sessions a couple weeks later i was like
the only thing that is different
is kiefer you think keifer's made you
happy okay so so okay you think i'm
crazy and i probably am but
i go on reddit your favorite website
and
i start searching kiefer and then all
these people are saying the same thing
that it has because the other thing i
noticed is that
um how do i put this uh
mildly
my dookie was good
you know what i'm saying like
to put it bluntly
like that i was regulated in a way that
i've only been regulated if i started
taking supplemental fiber which i just
don't like doing
because it's hard to keep up with and it
sucks yeah
but kefir had the same impact on my
gastrointestinal system that
supplemental fiber did
but also my mood was elevated and of
course i haven't read i'm sure you're
all like oh there's all these i know
there's all these books about your your
gut biome and the neurons in your
stomach and there's all this science
behind it that i'm not familiar with but
i'm just saying anecdotally is just a
dude who's been eating a lot of kefir
i'm telling you right now you scraped
out the sad causing bacteria and
replaced it with it i don't know but
then
literally i'm i'm not kidding you forgot
i ran out of kefir like
a month ago
okay
i went for
10 days without eating kefir and i found
myself i woke up one day and i'm like
i'm sad
what's different i was like it's the
damn kiefer
got to kiefer told jesse we got to have
kiefer we can't run out you got back to
the keefer got back to the kiefer
i'm i'm two weeks back in the keeper
kiefer
i'm happy
i it could it's probably totally
psychosomatic i understand that but i'm
saying
it could be placebo effect
but you should try it i like it but
here's i like being happy don't stop
just keep it coming keep it going
doesn't come in a big enough container
is there like a cheap version of it get
two
i guess you know it's
it's crazy yeah
i need it in bulk you can afford kefir
a lot better than mountain dew nico
that's ultimately what i'm saying if we
could just get kiefer to be caffeinated
we'd be
maybe that could be a product
it's like it's drinkable yogurt that
makes you happy
hey listen i swear by it kiefer's a
keeper
you know i should come up with all kinds
of funny things to say on how i survived
my teenage years but
in all due honesty i really could not
have survived my teenage years without
my you know my support group my friends
my family because
i was
a way different person as a teenager
than i am now i i hated who i was as a
teenager but i've definitely grown more
like especially since high school high
school was bad for me but yeah i
literally could not have survived my
teenage years with all my friends
because the way my personality was i
probably would have just spiraled into a
deep depression and i'm glad i'm in a
way better place than i am now so
thank you for listening right like love
you guys
i love this response wow isn't this
great it might be better than kiefer i
know this that was like that was like
kefir in a voicemail
yeah and he didn't give his name so i
think he would call him kiefer kiefer
sutherland uh just called in to the to
the pod kiever thanks for sharing that
um you make an excellent point that when
you're in your teenage years you are not
in your final form
and
you can you can change for the better
and sometimes it's just about weathering
the storm of being a teenager to get to
the
next phase of your life where you can
start to pull it all back together you
know
or pull it together for the first time
i tell my kids this all the time and uh
i you know i was talking to log the
other day
he's 18.
he's going off to college in the fall
and
i don't remember the context of the
conversation i just remember saying
you have no idea
how much you're gonna change over the
next four years
like
you are going to change more
oh yeah statistically speaking over the
next four years then you will ever
change in any additional four year
subsequent four years for the rest of
your life
and i was like that's that's exciting
now that you need to change but you need
an uh you need to understand just how
wet your concrete is
huh you know what i'm saying
yeah yeah yeah i like that and
just
revel in that wetness man
you know what i'm saying because it gets
harder and harder and harder
well i
i don't know you know you say revel in
it but it makes me think okay you got to
be strategic about
who you know who you
to kiefer's point oh you can screw it up
for sure you know what you expose
yourself to
when you're morphing
you know you're morphing into who you're
gonna be
at a at a rate greater than any other
point in your life when you're a
teenager so it's like
you gotta you gotta be thinking about
that and
i mean you're talking about in the
college years too which yes
you're still in 10 years but
who you who your people are
if like makes a big difference show me
your friends and i'll show you your
future
yeah man i mean i'm so grateful for
the friends that we had in high school
and we've talked about them the friends
that we have in college like
uh you know we're going to denver
in like in a handful of weeks we're
going to have a like a college friend
getaway in denver the fact that like
we're still connected to these people
who actually care about us it's like
it's it's an awesome feeling to know
that like
you can
somebody cares about you and there's no
strings attached you know you've got you
having a support structure is so
important and it's not something that
you can just
you know you can't put a i guess you
could put a one ad in the paper or
whatever the
the
app version of that is now there's a
digital way to do that even if you look
at mythical beasts i draw lots of
comfort and just inspiration knowing
that
there's people who've connected because
of our content but then it's more about
their connections with each other than
it is with us now that's freaking
awesome
you know i mean whether it's because of
us or something else
i mean
yeah he makes a great point that like
um having a few key people in your life
that love you and
you know you can trust
makes all the difference in the world
and so i think about the people who
don't have that and it's like but you
can get it like that's the hope in this
is that like he said with my personality
and what i was prone to at that
phase of my life
like i don't think i would have made it
i wouldn't make it to become the person
that i was
destined to be so to speak if it wasn't
for people there along the way to i
don't know you know he didn't fill in
the the gaps but we all need to do that
for ourselves
yeah and i think that right support
direction
fill in the blank a uh
and inherent in that message is
you don't have to be a teenager for this
to be applicable
but
regardless of how
hopeless you feel at the this moment
don't let this moment
these circumstances define
don't let the present define your future
i guess is a better way to say it right
it's so hard to do that it's
very difficult to do that that's why
people can be helpful in that
but sometimes you like
because even when it comes to the
choices you're making that i mean the
whole show me your friends and i'll show
you your future the reason that makes
sense and to some degree it's not you
know
it's not like an airtight always
true thing but
the the reason is that we a lot of times
make decisions about who we're going to
surround ourselves with based on current
needs
needs for acceptance most often
need for belonging and those things are
not bad in and of themselves but if
you're
finding acceptance and belonging with
people who don't have your best interest
in mind then your future self wishes
they could come back to your present
self and say don't make that decision so
that's the thing try to
anticipate what would my future self
want me to what kind of decisions would
they want me to make right now
um
it's very tough to to do that but you
have to try
you have to try to
especially when it comes to who you're
choosing to associate with
yeah that that phrase of like finding
your people is something that we
use in our home a lot for
every stage of life you know whether
it's
lando
assimilating into elementary school
and now moving on to middle school
and then lincoln moved through middle
school and high school and lilly finding
her
her way and her
her people in college like at every
stage
and then you think about us
like even
you know like post college in and moving
out here to california we had each other
uh and we had our families
but we had to find a few more
friends we had to find some people yeah
that we could count on you know
and it's and until we did it felt
tenuous
you know moving out here
then you just have you we had a couple
of close friends that we kind of
jumped into
really quickly and those are very sound
decisions you know mm-hmm still close
to uh
to them but you know just adding to that
group and this it doesn't have to be big
but you
it's important no matter what so this is
not a teenage thing
but yeah i'm so i'm so glad that you
called in
kiefer
let's hear another one
hello rhett and link my name is savannah
and
i could not have survived my teenage
years without fan fiction what yep
and just so you know fanfiction doesn't
have to be super sexual and weird it can
just be like a normal story about your
favorite characters just going on a
silly little adventure and that's the
kind of thing that i like to read and
write eventually so i got into
fanfiction when i was around like 12 and
i started writing at like 13
and then throughout middle school and
high school i wrote a crap ton of fan
fiction
uh because i was also homeschooled so i
was very bored so i actually wrote
over 250 000 words up until i started
college and got way too busy which is
like two plus books i think roughly if
you average them out and that's not even
a lot compared to most fan fiction
writers
so
yeah i still love writing but fan
fiction is like my weird little hobby
that i don't tell anyone about because
people hear fan fiction and think
sex kink so
yep
that's that's it
thank you susanna we don't savannah
savannah savannah savannah
savannah if you want to call back in and
talk about being a furry too you can
debunk some of some of that stigma oh
come on you don't know that they're not
always this this is not a
i'm not saying diagram is not a circle
it's not i'm just i that was my way of
saying
thank you savannah for dismantling the
stigma of fan fiction for me fan fiction
is not fan friction
it's a sub genre well and we don't know
that i mean our experience with fan
fiction is just being uncomfortable
reading stuff about ourselves for a
gimmick well on the show i do know
someone and i also know this person
um
because the people who uh especially in
in fandoms that are fictional to begin
with i mean it's one thing for there to
be fan fiction about
two real dudes like us
um
but i'm talking about like you've got a
world that's been built by an author or
a tv show or whatever and then i mean
that fan fiction which is basically
people just taking the world that's
already been built and the characters
that have existed and telling new
stories that kind of exist within this
world um
that was a world i didn't know about
until we met somebody who actually has
contributed significantly to some of
those things
and
it totally makes sense first of all
and one of the really exciting things
that's happening
related to this and again i'm not smart
enough to be able to explain it or
understand it but something
with the blockchain
with blockchain technology collaborative
storytelling
is is making that uh is easing and
encouraging that process and inviting
more people and incentivizing more
people to be involved in that to
actually be able to take narratives
and shape them
which is pretty exciting stuff so
actually i think
um
i think that those who were the first to
begin writing fan fiction we're actually
just way ahead of the curve in terms of
what we're all going to be participating
in when it comes the way that we relate
to storytelling in the future because
the more you can be involved to the
point that you're actually manipulating
the outcome that you know
influencing the outcome
influencing the stories or telling the
own your own stories like that's going
to be just the way people interact with
stories a generation from now it's
starting now again i'm not it's really a
student of it i just know smart people
who know more about it than i do who say
things and i get 10 of it and can then
re spit it out like this but it's
exciting if you think about it in terms
of okay favorite book series lord of the
rings
it's there's an incredible
world that's that's been built it's a
playground i'm sure that there's there's
got to be fan fiction
all around the world of talking right so
of course i just found myself well i
just don't
i'm not a reader and i'm not a writer
right so it's like do i have to be
what you're laughing at me
i mean i i can read yeah and i can write
uh prove it but that is not uh
that you know
that's not central to my id it's not one
of my major hobbies
yeah you're making me defensive
well i'm not a reader and a writer i'm
not you can snicker all you want what
i'm what i'm saying is that the and also
this is something that this is something
that mike helped me understand about
dungeons and dragons which i didn't
really understand
the appeal of dnd
but you're just making your own it's a
collaborative storytelling process but
my point what i was getting at was
i i assume because i'm so into the world
of talking that like
it just seems like there's a barrier to
okay this is just a fan generated story
it's not canon so it's not talking
yeah so
uh
but like if you look at the the star
wars universe lots of fan fiction there
absolutely as well like every every
place you can think of there's fan
fiction but like with star wars it's not
like everything's george lucas anymore
it's like you look at the john favreau
stuff and isn't the j is it yeah the
mandalorian fan fiction
or is it sophisticated well-funded fan
fiction but it's fan fiction did george
lucas did the originator of the story
come up with it no it was like right oh
this is a story that you can tell so
what i'm saying is fan fiction is
already it's officially sanctioned it's
just well-funded fan fiction is on
disney plus or whatever you know i i'm
just saying this is this is a revolution
in storytelling but when it becomes
canon like that stuff
is it it it's certified
yeah so then
there's like buy-in to because when it
builds a world and especially with all
the star wars stuff part of the fun
for me is like fitting it all together
but all you have to do you know because
i'm not i'm not gonna i'm not sitting
around waiting
so fan fiction there's a lot of fun
that's
when you don't k beyond canon
and that's the part that i don't i
haven't never experienced it so i think
that's my barrier to entry but you've
experienced the curated fan fiction as a
person who likes to watch television i
know it could be entertaining and
there's really talented people writing
fan fiction
i in theory
but i've not experienced it and i'm just
really curious
how
if i could get over that hurdle of like
i'm just reading this for the fun of it
but this chara this didn't really happen
to this character
but did the first thing happen to you no
because it's a fictional you think that
sam and uh frodo are actually best
friends
you know what one day you'll find out
i'm actually smarter than you
you know
that's going to blow your mind well
first of all why do you take anything
that i said as a as a critique on your
level of attention you laughed at me for
not being a reader or writer the only
thing i laughed at was when you said no
i'm not a reader or a writer it's like
that's just funny i thought it was a
joke
it's not a joke i thought you were
making a funny i thought it was pretty
funny it was i guess unintentionally
funny but what i'm saying is me man
is that
i might i feel like my eyes are being
open to the possibilities
not in a way that i'm directly
contributing to or experiencing you're
saying the same thing i'm saying
but i'm just saying that i think it's
pretty cool what's happening and i think
that it's going to be second nature for
our kids and our especially our kids
kids who are going to grow up in a world
in which the lines between
the fan fiction that savannah's talking
about and the fan fiction everyone is
experiencing which is just cool world
building
and stories that come from that world
the lines are just gonna be blurred man
and then it's gonna be like is it good
or not
but what you're saying is that somebody
has to be in charge and i think this is
where the cool and again i don't
understand it the cool sort of
blockchain
generated
it's curated it's not completely just
like oh here's fan fiction that would
conflict with this fan fiction over here
but no the collaborative is creating fan
fiction that fits together and doesn't
contradict yeah yeah yeah yeah right
you're interested in the consistency
which i totally get that right that
matters to me and i think it matters to
most people
honestly
but i'm just saying that if you if you
get that curated sort of semi-regulated
fan fiction
and then regulate it in terms of quality
like that's
i'm open that's an exciting future i'm
open
and i'm also open to the kinky stuff so
this is why i could not survive my
change years without i don't think it's
that crazy
but
um i'm 19 now and i still do this and
whenever i was really sad or angry or
just you know really intense feelings as
a teenager
i would crush bath bombs and my friends
would always give me bath while i was
thinking i was taking baths but i would
go in my bathroom like after my parents
were asleep and i would just like crush
them like with my bare hands and it was
actually nice like it released a lot of
stress you'd be surprised but yeah
wow i like that crushing bath bombs
but not actually taking a bath with them
well you could get a two-for-one
crush and let it crumble into the water
yeah and then you i mean the double
stress relief
what do you do when you're angry
physically
when i'm angry
i mean
when i'm angry i mean i have taken a
walk
oh
um
i've definitely uh inadvertently sent
christy on a few walks
that's
christy goes on walks when
i perturb her uh you curse when you get
upset i curse when i curse when i get
upset yeah
but when i was a kid my mom told me to
go punch a pillow which i actually did
there's no satisfaction this is what i
was getting at there's no satisfaction
in punching a pillow you remember in my
room when you walked into my room and
there was that hole
in the wall yeah and it was exactly the
diameter of my heel
that's because i got mad at my brother
one time and i kicked
like kicked the wall with my heel and it
goes my heel boom got a high arch so it
goes right through
it was that way and so it was like a
donkey kick
it was a
no sideways oh like a bruce lee a
sidekick oh
and and you also kicked the bleachers
when you're playing basketball as a teen
and broke your toes and i will you're a
kicker and well i'm also a puncher
but not not a closed fist puncher
because i i i care about my
hands
i'm going to be honest with you guys i'm
going to be vulnerable here
last week
i was in my own bathroom
and i was going in and out of the closet
now i'm a tall man and i hit my head on
door i would hit my head on more door
frames if they're not regulation if
they're not six foot eight i hit my head
on them sometimes but i've actually
gotten really good at not hitting my
head on things because i subconsciously
lower my neck anytime lower my head any
time i go through a door frame
but sometimes with an especially short
door frame which for some reason the
frame between my bathroom and my
bathroom closet
is pretty low
and i normally don't think about this
but i went into the closet went to the
bathroom then forgot something and did
like a pivot where i took one step into
the bathroom and turned back around bam
hit my head
the crown of my head
on the door frame the metal door frame
where the thing slides oh gosh
and my immediate reaction was to punch
it
it was just like like a palm heel strike
palm heel strike to the wall next to the
door i didn't hit the door because the
door is a mere big mirror
i don't want to break anything i don't
want to bleed it josh would be proud
and it was just like and jesse was like
in the like
jesse was like 15 feet away and she was
like somebody's got issues or something
like i don't know what she said no you
just hit your head uh but no but but the
reason i did it is because i was already
mad about something else and i don't
even remember you never remember what
you're mad about that's right outside
what i'll say is that i've never hit a
person in anger with the exception of
john carson and john enzor
and one time that was in your defense
you're welcome okay um
but i know it was i've never had a
person that was like almost 40 years ago
but i've never hit a person in uh in
anger but i have hit a house like a home
if a wall is part of a home
i've hit a
car
um
i probably hit a pole
okay
they never seem to care
yeah i i mean i like crushing a bath
bomb but this this is it the reason that
just keep them stacked up the great
thing about your pocket punching or
kicking sheetrock and giving a little
bit
gives you a sense of relief pillows
they're not fighting back at all bath
bomb may be the perfect thing because
plaster it's like you're destroying it
there's a sense of satisfaction but
nobody's getting hurt except the bath
bombs
here's one
hey little
yo so my name's danielle
and this is going to be a very jinzy
answer
um i do not have survived
being a teenager without the block
button on social media
that thing was my best friend throughout
middle school and high school and i wish
there was an in-person version of it
love you guys bye
oh yeah danielle button
the block i mean if i if i had to in
experience social media as a teen
man i wouldn't be here i don't know i
just don't know would have done
something too stupid to recover from i
mean
man the block button yeah that
having a healthy relationship with a
black button is probably a really good
thing
uh
i've
i've never blocked anybody you ever
blocked anybody
i've muted
i'm a mute or not a blocker okay like
how how how much muting have you done
less than a dozen people in my life okay
so this is not a regular occurrence
um the reason and again danielle
if the black button got you through more
power to you and i know that there's a
difference between the blocking and the
muting
yeah um
when you when you when you kick the
the wall
between you and your brother's room and
he's in there
then you have the added benefit of him
knowing that you just put a hole in the
wall but if he's not in there
you just you just got some anger out
that's the difference between a block
and a mute
well and also if you're talking about
twitter
i think i'm right about this if you
block someone
they cannot see your tweets and they
cannot
include they can't tweet about you like
they can't like put you in their tweets
oh that's nice
but i know that they they can't see your
tweets anymore
a mute just means that you can't see
anything that they say
so there's a few like the reason i again
this is a little bit different probably
from for a public figure yeah but
um
blocking is
uh in one sense
it can be
because they know that it happened it
could be a scene as like literally an
act of offense yeah it is defensive but
it's
often interpreted as a as an act of
aggression even though it's not
um
but because people it's it can be
incendiary i guess it's what i'm saying
and so if you want to just
ignore the fire you mute if you want to
you know the mute is more about your
experience
only
yeah right and so
that's one reason i haven't blocked it
if you don't want people i like what it
is a good point though if you don't want
someone i guess on twitter dragging
dragging your name into a conversation
then the the block
is effective with that for sure you know
in general i'm just i just want to big
up
boundaries
so you know what what
you know you're walking through your
life
and you're have your there's there's
certain
types of interactions that you can
control the how much people penetrate
your boundaries
sometimes you can't but when you can
it's good to just take a moment and
assess like
what about
you know where do i draw the line for
this relationship on social media or
real life you know it's just it's it's
good to say
you know i am empowered to say
i need to draw the line here
or there or wherever it may be
agreed danielle
let's hit one more
hey rhett link this is jake from
illinois and i could not survive my
teenage years
without
school assemblies quite literally
because when i was about a freshman or
sophomore we had a school assembly
talking about the dangers of
getting out of your car when light poles
or telephone poles rather fall
and you're in your car
because we had a girl that actually got
out of her car when this happened
and she's lucky if the wires weren't
live still because otherwise she would
have got electrocuted died
but she lived and she along with some
other professionals gave
a assembly and inform the students what
to do if that was to ever happen to them
fast forward like two years later maybe
a year later
and my friends decided to get a storm
chasing
and
sure enough
the telephone poles that we're driving
by start falling like dominoes and we
get lucky and
our car is right in between two that
fall so we're trapped in between two
can't go anywhere
and because the education that we got at
this school assembly
we knew to stay in the car and just wait
till help got there to help us out and
it was a wild experience i was very
scared but hey
i survived my teenage years
i'll never forget that
wow jake you gotta pay attention to
those school assemblies man now
jake needs to have a school assembly
where he tells people not to go storm
chasing
right well i mean
i don't know because if well the thing
about the the wires falling on your car
is that if you step out you're creating
you're completing the circuit with the
ground and it's gonna it's gonna go
through you trying to get to the
ground wow so
i think that's a great way to end this
discussion is by reminding people
if you're in a car with a with a rogue
power line draped over you
don't get out of the car
wait for help to come
take it from jake do you remember
anything from a school assembly the only
thing i remember from a school assembly
is that one from the prom oh yeah the
the guy would come in and show off i
don't
do that slide show of intoxicated people
drunk driving
he then have been maimed good kids
there's things i cannot get out of my
mind yeah and i gotta say right now it
was effective i wasn't about to drive
drunk
uh
because i wasn't especially on a moped
because i wasn't even drinking but like
yeah man like i think any any time i am
faced with the opportunity
to drive
while intoxicated which is not not often
you think about that that's good
the first thing comes to mind is this is
really stupid don't do this and the
second thing is that dagum school
assembly assembly in 1996 before the
prom
um i'm going to give a wreck but first i
just want to give a teaser to next
week's ear biscuit
rhett's gonna
how do i how do i put this
there's gonna be a big episode next week
teaser where
rhett's gonna unleash
some news
that um
you know honestly i think it'd be good
for us to process it together
okay
so
be sure to come back next week i will
say that for some news i won't be um
this won't be breaking the seal if you
if you
you know follow me on social media right
so you're gonna you'll probably already
know about this you'll probably know
about it right now you know about his um
his project
yeah but we're going to talk all about
that
personal project
we're going all the details next week
here on your biscuits hashtag your
biscuits lesson let us know what's going
on i'll leave you with a wreck
um
you wrecked this to me you may have
wrecked it on the podcast i think i did
but i can't i have to wreck this because
i i just i finally got around to
watching a few nights ago the
documentary called beauty is
embarrassing about the artist wayne
white if you're
a creative person and you want
to just this is just a profile of an
artist who
just his he's just got this artistic
ethos about him that's just very
inspiring
he designed a lot of the puppets for
pee-wee's playhouse
did a lot of other things he's an
eclectic
uh
creator
of art
and it's just a fun
podcast to just like be introduced to
wayne white podcast i said podcast i'm
just not a possibility it's a
documentary
yeah it's just like an hour and you know
an hour and a half
um
very inspiring very inspiring character
yep beauty is embarrassing
if you're if you're into artistic
profiles this is a fun one thank you for
your voicemails keep leaving them ask us
questions participate in the prompts
that we put out on social media tell us
what you think what you want what you
fear what you love
one eight eight eight earpod one
and you might get featured at the end of
an episode just like right now
so basically i'm just gonna say i could
not have survived my teenage years
without
geez whiz rhett i know you know what
that one means hi written link i could
not have survived my teenage years
without scrambled pay-per-view channels
if you know you know
hey rhett and link uh long time listener
first time caller to answer your prompt
what could i not live without as a
teenager i'd have to say you guys it's
kind of cheesy but i've been watching
you for a long time since i was real
little about seven and i've really loved
growing up with you guys and you've been
like parental figures to me um but if
you wanted a real answer pornography
to watch more ear biscuits click on the
playlist on the right to watch the
previous episode of your biscuits click
on the playlist to the left and don't
forget to click on the circular icon to
subscribe if you prefer to listen to
this podcast it's available on all your
favorite podcast platforms thanks for
being your mythical best
[Music]